this is from a Twitter user I was
talking to a female friend and she was
telling me how lonely it is for her to
be working with only men in her team
because they all maintain a respectful
distance from her as they don't want to
come off as creeps not realizing it's
completely isolating I do not care
I gotta choose me
I gotta cheat on me
I I gotta choose me
like I know it might be hard because
you're lonely but
I gotta choose me
you being lonely in your career is Gonna
Make You Lonely in your career but I
gotta choose me I can't work with even
trying to pass as a creep for something
that I thought I I didn't even do and
that she interpreted and I don't want to
take the chance
first and foremost I don't know who I'm
working with what baggage a person has
with it and I don't want to deal with
that I don't know what your triggers are
sometimes it's not what I do the
triggers that you have
yeah sometimes it's not what I do it's
the trigger that you have it might
happen not often but it'll just take one
time it's just like one time
I gotta choose me the same way that I'm
not gonna fall every time I take my
motorcycle
I'm not gonna fall every time
every time I have a ride it's wonderful
as a matter of fact with all the years I
ride motorcycles which is 12 for 14
years now
I've only found once
but only take that one time
does that mean I'm not gonna put an
element on does that mean I'm gonna go
out with my t-shirt without my
protection no I put my protection on I
put my helmet on because it only take
one time and now one time I'm not gonna
recuperate from that I gotta choose me
my girl
okay be lonely
but I gotta choose me okay well let me
let me finish
so someone else replied I would think in
this case your friend needs to break the
ice to which she replied she did that
many times they still continue their
behavior
and then she goes on says that's exactly
my point whatever they're doing it's
just to make us feel safer I hate that
there's so much pressure on them to do
so but well if a lady is trying to get
herself included she's still gonna be
getting ignored then I feel like
something has to be said all this to say
on this topic I sympathize because
unfortunately the women are bearing the
brunt of the fact that some other women
are acting inappropriate at work or
saying things that are foul or making
rumors or starting issues or if it's not
even other women sometimes it's a boss
who sees you interacting with somebody
else and they take it upon themselves to
think something inappropriate is
happening people file you know
complaints on behalf of others it
happens all the time with HR and so now
you are bearing the brunt of other
women's Behavior which is unfair
but in that same token as man we bear
the bread to the fact that other men are
creepy right when I'm walking home late
at night and there's a girl in front of
me and she's terrified of Me Okay
because we're the only two people on the
street and we're going in the same
direction I'm not like why is this [__]
being so weird I know why I understand
it even though I've never done anything
like that even though I'm not like hey
time to break right even though I don't
do that I understand why she's scared
because unfortunately you better run and
it's unfair you want to be seen as an
individual but like preach said
when it comes to workplace Dynamics
unfortunately these things have
consequences I can't go into the
workplace and talk a certain way why
because I understand the perception that
people are going to have as a black man
I don't complain about it I don't [__]
and moan about it it just is what it is
so do I understand the frustration sure
well what do I think about it
welcome to the Maine's world
[Music]
yeah
yeah if men are doing things to protect
themselves in the workplace that's fine
workplace is not for fraternization it's
not for friendships and friendization
includes friendships it's not it's not
for that of course those things make
work a lot more fun and enjoyable but we
ain't needed
I'm trying to get paid I'm trying to pay
bills I'm trying to take care of my
family Finance for the future not trying
to make friends and I will not let
trying to make someone feel a little bit
extra comfortable put that in Jeopardy
in any type of way and I'm telling you
this right now in corporate environments
there's more and more and more red tape
being added they're being there's
there's extra scrutiny being involved in
those workplaces so am I mad at these
dudes for doing what they did no do I
understand the frustration of women sure
but you know welcome to what we've been
dealing with you know what I'm saying
guys will tell you we know what it is
we're constantly aware of the fact that
we look threatening to women
constantly yeah on dates and workplaces
everything I always have to make sure
I'm thinking in my head oh she might
feel threatened in this moment how do I
change my behavior to make her feel at
ease I keep a certain distance I never
make eye contact I never even try to go
and talk to her initiate any
conversation you might not believe it
but I do all of that so she doesn't even
have the opportunity to think something
will just happen and guess what some of
these crazy [__] still think that it
is some of these women will still think
you're trying to try something so I'm
like I ain't even
I don't want that headache because that
one negative experience is not worth a
10 positive even when I'm walking down
the street like crossing a woman I mean
I know I know let's say you cross a
woman right you're on the side of the
road there's building on this side right
and she coming this way right
most women notice this voice most women
are going to look at the buildings or
look down or look down just because they
don't want to draw your attention yep
what do I do I look away yup just to
show her that hey I'm not even about
that life you don't want to look at me
[__] I don't want to look at you I'm
not even looking hey oh if I go and we
cross if we go and I'm like look at my
phone I put my phone away and I'll look
up and she's and she's looking at me
like we cross out I smile and I look
down yup or and look away I'm not this
is this is I'm not even about you right
now damn right that you so you could
walk don't even worry I'm not gonna try
to holler at y'all I'm gonna try to do
nothing I understand why you understand
why but I understand that's what I gotta
do I understand that you feel a certain
type of window where I look the way I am
you don't know why you don't know why me
you don't know what what but I'm telling
I'm sending the message I'm not about
that so you good and I'm not saying this
to someone who's been through it I've
already had that negative experience
someone I never spoke to lost her
[__] Marbles and trying to make up
some whole sword thank you there's like
dozens of witnesses so it didn't matter
but for a while like my name got dragged
through the mud I'm dealing with that
[__] you best believe I learned how to
keep the most professional distance at
workplaces because it wasn't necessary
and the risks just weren't worth it so
my thoughts like I said I made it I'm
mad at them but I understand the
frustration like sometimes working
somewhere
can suck but the people make it amazing
and just feeling like you don't get to
have that experience of having like
close bonds with your co-workers and
stuff like that that can really feel
isolating
my girl let's work
they're not ignoring you they're being
professional
move on they're being professional
yeah especially if there's a law and a
clause of Norful tonight fraternization
in your environment they are being
professionals
you're going to not be lonely outside of
work that's why we have extracurricular
activities okay yeah yeah my girl go out
with your girlfriends or with your
friends outside of work get yourself
some friends that are outside of work at
work we stay professional yay
I'm not enjoying this I'm just happy
that [__] are safe and doing
the same thing enough times that we are
happy that people are saying it sounds
like you spite women no not at all so I
was like you got a little bit of the
thing that happened is that a lot of the
times that we're like we come here and
then we we we uh we comment on things
like that right and we're like yeah man
you should have done the right thing
with it and I'm happy that now these
[__] are doing the right thing
I'm happy that nothing is nothing
ambiguous is being taken yeah you know
there's no positive people are not
taking the possibility so it's not
despite women I'm happy that people we
we cover a lot of dumb [__]
there's a lot of dumb [__] there you
know talking [__] preach we cover a lot
of dumb [__] there's a lot of dumb [__]
that happens and we're like yo you
should have done better you should have
known better and now I'm just really
happy that [__] are listening
and they're actually saved so yeah it's
unfortunate that it feels like that in
the work environment because environment
you know sometimes you want it to be fun
you want to you know you want to be able
to enjoy yourself but yeah I gotta
choose me
and same thing with the girls sometimes
you don't want you don't want guys to
interpret what you it goes both ways
actually
the same way that if you work with men
you don't want man you don't want you
don't want you don't wait you don't want
men to interpret certain things
and then put yourself in a position so
you keep like a safe distance that the
repercussion is not the same I
understand that not agree but yeah when
you said like it goes both ways I'm like
it does it
see that's what I'm saying they get to
do that at work with no repercussions
the same way I get to do that in this
Dynamic with no Reapers
no I'll tell you yeah you know tell them
no I'll tell you what's gonna happen I
got the police on speed doc go ahead I
got it yeah yeah and you look
threatening so they gonna shoot you and
I'll be ducking for cover they gonna
shoot at both of us they're going
through that you first and then they're
gonna ask me questions because I'm white
passing no they're gonna hear how I
speak both of us hello sir yes this this
this oh over here threatening my life
my name Jimmy it is what it is anything
else nope all right let us know what you
guys think in the comments below we want
to hear from you